reste à montréal l'aéroport est il en
train d'être totalement déclassé par les
autres villes du pays c'est un débat qui
revient assez souvent cette fois ce sont
les élus municipaux qui réclament qui
réclament plus de vols directs en
partance de la métropole pour corriger
la situation
bonjour et françois cormier françois a
fait on dit que montréal est nettement
désavantagée par mon toronto et
vancouver et calgary
ce sont des élus du parti de marcel côté
la coalition montréal qui disent que ça
n'a pas de bon sens que vancouver
toronto calgary et une croissance qui
soit beaucoup plus rapide que la
croissance de montréal il donne un
exemple
air canada ajoute des vols à destination
du japon et en aura évidemment de ces
trois villes là mais aucun vol à partir
de montréal lors ils disent faut
commencer faut continuer faut faire
encore plus de pression sur les
transporteurs disent que parfois
faudrait peut-être que ce soit les gens
toronto qui fasse escale à montréal et
pas le contraire
et selon hubert tout ça ça nuit à
l'économie et les gens ne sont pas
attirés à montréal parce que parfois
faut faire escale même chose pour les
investisseurs on peut écouter un conseil
municipal
on pense qu'il y à marcher à montréal
chez honda hm souffle à ces marchés si
on donne des choix aux montréalaises
essais on donne des choix aux
investisseurs qui veut venir au canada
réaction d'aéroports de montréal
aéroport qui visiblement n'est pas
contente en fait on nous disait les
politiciennes montréal parle beaucoup
mais y'a pas beaucoup d'actions qui sont
faites par eux il donne un exemple
l'aéroport pet 40 millions en taxes
municipales alors qu'à toronto ses 27
millions toronto qu'un hara europorte 2
fois plus gros et il faudrait peut-être
commencer par là pour être plus
compétitif conteste à peu près tous les
chiffres qui sont avancés par les élus
de la coalition montréal et disent que
finalement l'exemple du japon mais c'est
parce qu'il aurait pas assez de monde
finalement qui prendrait les vols à
destination du japon à partir de
montréal tous les sens dans le pdg
d'aéroports de montréal
nous sommes très bien servi pour une
ville de notaire on peut pas prétendre
que nous sommes trop tôt c'est difficile
pour god mariage job et l'économie et
déménager là il ya quelques années et
c'est sûrement pas la faute des eyrieux
points de monya alors voilà pour ce qui
est de l'aéroport patrice est un mot
pour vous dire que c'est jour de conseil
municipal aujourd'hui avait une
nomination qui était très attendue celle
de denis gallant qui donc a été confirmé
dans ses fonctions il surveillait de la
balustrade l'aï sera de y sera donc à
partir de demain matin inspecteur
général il veut se mettre au travail
pas de pouvoir pour l'instant puisque la
loi n'est pas passée mais bon il va
former son bureau est dit que les gens
pourront le contacter dès demain pour
lui donner des informations d'ailleurs
un bureau qui ne sera pas située à
l'hôtel de ville pour vraiment créer une
distance avec l'administration
très bien merci en soi au revoir